وقع لمين العام للنيتو هو رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ورئيس المجلس الاوروبي في
بروكسل اعلانا المشتركه للتعاون والتنسيق
ردا على ما سميناه اخطر تهديد للامن منذ
عقود يتضمن الاعلان تعاهدا لتعزيز التعاون
بين الجانبين في مواجهه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا كما تطرق الى الصين واصفا ياها
بالتحدي لعالم نيورادو تغييره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاش ثلاثه مسارات ما هو
سياق الدولي الذي جاء فيه هذا الاعلان
المشترك وما مغزى توقيته وبماذا يختلف عن
اعلانات تعاون سابقه بين طرفين
ما تحديات المشتركه التي يواجهها النت
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي وما الذي يعنيه
التطرق الى الصين لاول مره يتحد لمبادئ
الشريكين في مواجهه عالم يراد تغييره كما
جاء في الاعلام
وكيف سينعكس هذا الاتفاق على مستقبل
القاره الاوروبيه وعلاقتها مع الشرق
والغرب وما تاثيره على النزاعات الاقليميه
والدوليه
[موسيقى]
هو الاعلان الثالث الذي يتم توقيعه بين
الجانبين منذ 2016 من اجل تعزيز تعاوني
بينهما في عالم يزداد اضطرابا نسخه جديده
الى الملف الصيني الذي اخذ حيزا هاما
انتهت المباحثات الى تشديد الجانبين على
ما اعتبره اخطر تهديدا للامن منذ عقود
وفيما يتعلق بالجين ذهب الاعلان الى ان
الصين بتتمثل تحديا لما بادئ الطرفين واذا
كان دعم اوكرانيا في وجه روسيا قد مثل قطب
رحل اتفاق فان ذلك لن ينهي جدلا داخل
البيت الاوروبي مداره مطالب بسياسه دفاعيه
اوروبيه اكثر استقلاليه
[موسيقى]
بمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من بنسلفانيا
مايكل ريان نائب مساعد وزيره الدفاع
الامريكي السابق لشؤون اوروبا
نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس ومن
جنازه الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه
من الولايات المتحده بالسؤال
عن هذا الاعلان بماذا يختلف عن الاعلانات
السابقه
وما مخزى هذا التوقيت ان يعلن التعاون
والتنسيق بين الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي في
هذا الوقت وتذكر فيه الصين ربما بشكل اوضح
شكرا على هذا السؤال كما ذكرت هذه هذا ليس
الاتفاق الاول الذي تم توقيعه هذا مؤشر
على تعاون اوسع واعمق بين حلف الناتو بين
الادوات والمؤسسات موجوده في الاتحاد
الاوروبي والتي تتضمن المفوضيه الاوربيه
21 دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهم اعضاء في
النيته بالتالي هذا الامر يؤكد على ان
اعضاء
المنظمتين
يريدون ان يتم دمج امكانيات الطرفين بشكل
مكثف لكي يعمل بشكل اكثر قربا وبالتالي
زياده فعاليه قدراتهم في دعم الامن
والاستقرار في اوروبا الشمالي امريكا
بالتالي هذا تغيير وتطور لسنوات عديده
عملتهم لنفسه في عام 2003 الى 2010 في
المراحل الاولى للتعاون بين الاتحاد
لكن كما ذكرت فان العلاقات علاقات الدول
الاعضاء ايضا تاثرت بعلاقتها بالصين ايضا
بالتالي هذا تطور طبيعي للامور سيد اندريه
همموف موسكو كيف تلقت هذا الاعلان الجديد
عن التعاون بين الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي
وخصوصا ان التصريحات التي تلت هذا الاعلان
تحدثت عن نتائج عكسيه اتت بها الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا بحيث وحدت الموقف
الاوروبي وموقف النيته واصبح اكثر تماسكا
وقربا من ذي قبل
ابو
جبسون
يشاهدوننا ولكن اريد ان اقول ان في موسكو
بعد التعرف القريب الى الاعلانات
هو بعد سماع نص
المؤتمر المشترك
ظهرت
لدينا شعور بالراحه
لان كنا نتوقع ان هناك اوضاع ماساويه قد
تؤدي الى الوصول الى نتائج او وثيقه
اجراميه ولن ولم يحدث هذا وانا كشخص
بالقران بتاريخ دبلوماسي ان الوثيقه ضعيفه
جدا وهي ضد كل التوقعات ولا يحتوي على اي
شيء جديد في مجال التعاون بين النيته
والاتحاد الاوروبي
ومنظماته اما بالنسبه للمساله التي تناقش
بشكل موسع حيث
يذكرون الصين اذا اخذنا بعين الاعتبار
الوثيقه بحد ذاتها وما همم نصت عليه
بالنسبه للصين كان هناك حديث حذر جدا
وهذا شاهد على ان
الصي انهم يخشون الصين بشكل حقيقي في
اوروبا ولا يريدون ان يفسدوا العلاقات مع
الصين لذلك اعتقد ان هدف هذا اللقاء كان
ان يخيفوا البعض في الصين او الروس ولم
يستطيع فعل هذا لذلك همم
لديهم عمليات
سيئه الانتاج والاخراج
للمسؤولين عن هذا
منظمه لكن يعني لفتني القول ان روسيا كانت
تتوقع شيء اكثر دراماتيكيه همم كما فهمت
ما الذي كانت تتوقع روسيا من هذا الاجتماع
ولم يحصل لكن باختصار ارجوك
برنس
المجتمع الاوروبي
يضع لنفسه سؤال
ان مساله الامن لم تحل بعد لذلك
والمجتمع الاوروبي هم
يوجدون فيه وقائع مختلفه الواقع الاقتصادي
والواقع العسكري
وليس هناك اي تقارب بين هذه الجوانب في
هذه الوثيقه لم يحدث هذا تماما بالنسبه
لنا هذا خبر جيد ان هذه التشكيلات قد
اعلنت اعلانات
فارغه ولم يحدث اي شيء جديد همم دكتور
عبيده
هلك النظره مختلفه لهذا الاعلان عن
الاعلانات السابقه عن السياق الذي جاء فيه
وخصوصا مع حديثه عن تحدي روسيا وتحدي ايضا
المستقبلي للصين في علم يرادوا تغييره كما
جاء في الاعلان
يعني التحديات القديمه والتحديات الجديده
باعتبار ان هذه الحرب يعني مستمره طول امد
الحرب في اوكرانيا مع تداعيات والتكلفه
كبيره على المستوى العسكري والمستوى
السياسي مستوى الاقتصادي المستوى البيئي
جعلت من الاتحاد الاوروبيه يقتنع في
النهايه ويضع حد بعض الخلافات الداخليه
حول ما يسمى كما تعلم داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي بين الاوروبيين والاطلسيين الذين
يدعون الى دفاع مشترك اوروبي مستقل عن
الاطلسي ودول الاخرى تعمل من اجل ان تكون
هناك علاقه قويه جدا اعتقد ان الجناح
الثاني انتصر
ورفع رفع درجه الشراكه والتعاون بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي والحلف ال- ال- الاطلسي
يعني من شانها قبل كل شيء تقليل الخسائر
ثم كذلك ان يكون هناك تنسيق لانه كان هناك
نوع من عدم التناغم داخل العمليات
العسكريه التنسيق العسكري ما بين مثلا
قيادات الاركان في الاتحاد الاوروبي ومن
حلف الاطلسي كل هذه الامور تم التطرق
اليها بالد هلا من الاسبوع المقبل سيكون
هناك اجتماع فانا اعتقد ان حجم التحديات
وكذلك ربما عدم اليقين الان في الظرفيه
الدوليه التي جعلت من الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقتنع بانه لا مفر من تكثيف العلاقه مع
الاحتفاسي طيب ولكن في هذه النقطه هل تجد
في هذا الاعلان اعلانا استراتيجيا يؤسس
لمراحل جديده ام انه اعلان منظر فيهم
فرضته ظروف الحرف في في اوكرانيا وقد
يتغير مع تغير الظروف الراهنه
يعني يجب امام منظمه عسكريه وانا اعتقد
هناك العديد من القضايا الخاصه القضايا
مثلا
بكيفيه التعامل مع التحديات يعني لن تظهر
للعلن لكن هذا الاعلان الثالث هو في
النهايه اعلان للشراكه هناك نوع من
الشراكه الجديده همم اعتقد انه في هذا
الاعلان نحس بان هناك رغبه جديده ونحس
كذلك بان هناك اراده همم من قبل كل الدول
الاوروبيه بان يكون فعلا هناك تعاون عسكري
لكن لا المهم جدا وان الحلف الاطلسي يخرج
منصر لان القضايا لان لم تصبح فقط كما كما
قراءه البيان لم تسبح فقط قضايا عسكريه
اصبحت سياسيه اصبحت مناخيه اي ان الحلف
الاطلسي الذي انشا سنه الاربع عنايات من
اجل الدفاع المشترك الان اصبح حلف اطلسي
لموجه لكل التحديات مما يعني بان الحلف
الاطلسي اصبح الان هو همم الواجهه الوحيده
المتوفره الان للدول الغربيه
مشاهدينا فيما يتعلق بالابعاد العمليه
لهذا الاتفاق قال الامين العام الناتوينس
طلسم برج ان الشراكه معلتي حد الاوروبيه
مهمه اكثر من اي وقت مضى وان هناك حاجه
لزياده مستوى الدعم العسكري المقدم
لاوكرانيا
اكثر من اي وقت مضى لان اجتياح روسيا
الغاشيه لاوكرانيا غير بشكل امننا في
الايام الاخيره راينا القتال الشديد
الدائره في شرق اوكرانيا الذي يظهر شجاعه
القوات هناك ويظهرون كذلك اهميه الدعم
العسكري الذي يجب ان نزيته لذلك ارحب
بالاعلان من قبل الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والمانيا تقديم اسلحه متنوعه ودبابات
خفيفه وبكل الدعم المقدمي من الحلفاء
والشركات
هذا الاتفاق المعلن الى اي ماذا يحظى
باجماع حقيقي هو في النهايه حصل الاتفاق
وجرى توقيعه لكن داخل دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي حيث تصدر اصوات خصوصا ما يتعلق
بالدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا اصوات همم غير
ملحده بشكل بهذا المستوى من الدعم الان ما
مدى الاجماع على ما اتفق عليه
نعم اعتقد ان هنالك اتفاق ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي والنيتو يعملون في قضايا الدفاع
والامن على مساله التوافقات بمعنى ان على
كل الدول ان توافق
بقت اعلان هذا اعلان ياتي بعد اجتماع
مجلس الاوروبي بمعنى اجتماع الدول الاعضاء
بالتالي هم سيكون قد وافقوا على هذا
الاعلان وبالتالي بعد في اعقابي
العطل الاعياد الميلاد راس السنه
الميلاديه الجديده انا همم مرتاح همم
زميلي في مصر همم فوائد
امر في هذا الاتفاق ان هذا الاعلان ياتي
تعميقي تعميقي التعاون انا كان هنالك
اعلان السنه الماضيه وايضا كان المفهوم
النيته الذي تم توافق عليه في شهر يونيو
وعلى مستوى رؤساء كل الوثيقتين تذكر
التعاون الذي سيحصل بين المنظمتين وايضا
على البناء التحتيه المهمه من اجل التعامل
في قضايا مثلا
هنالك في التعامل مع الهجمات السيبرانيه
مثلا وتمديدات الاخرى ويتم التعامل معها
على انها ربما
اساليب حرب في وقت السلام وقد كانت دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيترو تتعامل مع هذا
الامر خلال سنوات الخمسه عشر الماضيه
ووصلوا الى نقطه انهم بشكل كامل لانهم
ملتزمون بمواجهتها هذا الامر بالتالي خلق
ضروره للكلى المنظمتين وتعميق التعاون
بينهما لان كل منهما لديهما بعض الادوات
وسويهم يمتلكون كل الادوات الضروريه التي
تمكنهم من الدفاع عن انفسهم عن اي و- اا
طرف قد يكون له همم مشكله مع ما يرغبون
بالقيام به بالتالي هو اعلان مهم اللي حول
التنميه الوطنيه لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
وايضا جاء في وقت المناسب
لا يقلق همم موسكو همم التاكيد والتشديد
الاوروبي مع الناتو على المواجهه وعلى
التنسيق والتعاون وخصوصا انه ياتي كما
يبدو ااه
بادره تقابل ذلك التقارب الصيني الروسي
وبالتالي همم ربما يكون هناك حائط صد اذا
همم هذه الجبهه الصينيه الروسيه من قبل
النيته ودول الاتحاد الاوروبي
نحن نقوم بتطوير التعاون مع الصين قبل اي
شيء من الطرفين بشكل من الطرفين ومن المهم
هنا واقول بكل صراحه المهم هنا هو عامل
موقف الولايات المتحده
اعتمادا على
اعتمادا على علاقات الولايات المتحده مع
الصين
وروسيا وعلى هذا الاساس قد يتغير التعاون
العسكري بيننا وبين الصين اما بالنسبه
لاوروبا قد
احزن الزملاء في اوروبا ولكن
الصين ليست عاملا مهما بين الجانب
الاوروبي ونحن
في كثير من الاحوال نهمل وجهه النظر النظر
الاوروبيه لانها ليست نظره لاصدقاء
وسوف ننظر الى وجهه النظر الاوروبيه فقط
بعد النصر الروسي في اوكرانيا
وكيف سوف يتعامل مع هذا الدول الاوروبيه
التي قد تتراجع عن العدوانيه ضد روسيا
العدوان الذي استمر طول 30 سنه نحن لا
نستعجل كما ترون في اوكرانيا لاننا نحتاج
للوقت حتى تستطيع
القوات العسكريه من تقويه نفسها الان ليس
هناك اي جيش في العالم بشكل حقيقي ممكن ان
يستعد حرف همم ربما بعد سيتين سنتين قد
يظهر هذا وسوف تكون القوه الروسيه هي
القوه الجاهزه حقيقي همم روسيا فقط هي
القوه الجاهزه الجميع يتفقد استعداداته
وتحالفاته
واستراتيجياته منذ اندلاع حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وبالنظر لمتغيرات اخرى لا تقل
عنها اهميه من قبيله تطورات ملف الخلاف
بين الصين
وتحركات بجين على خلفته وكذلك التجارب
صاروخيه المتكرره لكوريا الشماليه اتحولات
التي طرات على سياسات اليابانيه مثلت
مضمونه تقريرا لصحيفه واشنطن بوس نقلت فيه
عن رئيس الوزراء اليمنيوكاشيده قوله في
رساله تحذيريه الى الولايات المتحده
والدول الاوروبيه يقول اوكرانيا اليوم قد
تصبح اسيا غدا هذا السؤال مواجه للدكتور
همم حسني عبيده
هل نحن هو اا امام ظروف تتشكل
لتستنسخ تلك التجربه في ااا اوكرانيا همم
في اسيا من خلال حرب صينيه على تايوان
هناك تخوف كبير من حلفاء الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في المنطقه
ومن بعد اعضاء الحلف الاطلسي اكثر من ذلك
هناك تخوف من قبل الدول الاوروبيه اصلا من
محدوديه الدفاع الاوروبي المشترك امام
تداعيات امام الاستمرار الحرب على دول
اوروبيه واظهر اصلا محدوديتها في الدفاع
على اوكرانيا شبه جزيره القرم وحتى في
وحتى في جورج فنحن فعلا هنا امام السياسه
عندما ترى بان درجه او مستوى الانفاق
العسكري الصيني والثلاثين مره اكثر من
الانفاق الاوروبي وان كذلك الانفاق الروسي
ثلاث مرات اكثر من الانفاق الاوروبي نعرف
الان ونعلم نفهم جيد لماذا المانيا خصصت
100 مليار دولار ليه لميزانيتها العسكريه
والاتحاد الاوروبي تقريبا 200 مليار
اجمالا للانفاق العسكري نعم هناك تخوف
كبير من قبل مثلا من قبل اليابان من قبل
الاخرى كذلك ولذلك التحالفات التي تريد
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انت بنيها في
المنطقه تمر عبره دعم التحالف الاساسي
الاقدم والاوثق هو التحالف بين الحلف
الاطلسي وبين الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتبر
فعلا المنطقه الرخوه المنطقه الاقل ضعف
باعتبار ان لا يمكن لديها ليس لديها
القدره العسكريه ان تواجه تحديات متعدده
من من الشرق سيد مايكل همم ريان هل توافق
الولايات المتحده همم هذا التخوف الذي عبر
عنه رئيس الوزراء الياباني ان اوكرانيا
اليوم اسيا قد تكون همم غدا
وعندما تعتبر الصين تحدي همم للاتحاد
الاوروبي وايضا ما الاستراتيجيه العمليه
على ارض الواقع التي سيقوم بها النيته
لمواجهه هذا التحدي فعليه انا اسال
اكشن
الصراع في اوكرانيا في سياق ما سيحدث ربما
مستقبلنا في اسيا في ما يتعلق
بطموحات الصينيه لكي كما يقولوا لتوحيد مع
هنالك احتماليه ان رئيس الصيني كما قال ان
الاتحاد مع تايوان او عوده تايوان هو امر
ما حكم كيف سيحدث ذلك علينا
قلق حقيقي في الولايات المتحده وفي شمال
امريكا وفي اوروبا
يحصل عن طريق العسكريه والذي سيكون له
تاثير مدمر على القضايا الاساسيه التي
تجمع الولايات المتحده وهو الاقتصاد
العالمي في امريكا الشماليه وايضا اوروبا
الاقتصاد مرتبط بشكل كبير لكن
الاقتصاد الصيني هو شاب بحجم اقتصاد
الولايات المتحده وبسبب هذا التعامل بين
التبادل التجاري بين الولايات المتحده
والصين واوروبا والصين اي شيء قد يضر بهذا
التبادل التجاري بين هذه الاقطاب المهمه
للاقتصاد العالمي سيكون له عواقب سلميه
على العالم شكرا لك
دكتور حسني عبيده من جلال
[موسيقى]